over the course of last year tyson ten's
nyo has basically become a household
name in esports part of that is due to
his undeniable talent
oh
my god
but the other reason he's become such a
streaming staple is that he's just a
really likable goofy kid
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's just something about tenza's
personality that is insanely infectious
he has something to offer everyone but
beyond the jaw dropping he's done on
stream and on the competitive stage
there's a lot more to tens than people
know like his canine connection he
sounds so stupid but he has really cute
little pointy canine teeth he looked
like a straight out of an anime
character chat or how he's turned some
of twitch's biggest stars into his
biggest groupies
oh
there he is i can love him i could love
him here he comes
oh baby
nah the reavers dog dude
river is straight dog
12 seconds later
lens uses that op
okay why don't you say that in the first
place
so grab a snack and pull up a seat
because today we're going to be tackling
the tens iceberg and who knows what
we're going to find below the surface
lights on or like
lights i didn't read that question
lights on so you don't get eye damage
are they actually asking they're closing
what is it
oh
all right guys so before we start the
expedition i'd like to ask you to
subscribe to the channel and ring the
notification bell if you haven't already
and if you like what we're doing why not
like the video we've got to power the
station wagon somehow
and i'm pretty sure this thing's running
on fumes
okay there's definitely some kind of
fume in here i'm not really sure
all right no more faffing about it's
time to get into this iceberg approach
cautiously though we don't want to spook
it
what's in a name it only makes sense to
kick off our journey with a bit of an
origin story so how exactly did tens
become tens well it all started in a
very familiar place for a lot of gamers
out there call of duty zombies and
zombie is what he chose as his original
tag and i was just like damn let's just
be really cool and just add like a ton
of capitals and a ton of z's
and
make it like this
and so this is
ten how many in total there's ten zed's
so
later on i was like damn that looks kind
of stupid let me just do to that because
i'm bored
and then it went to this because there's
10 zeds zombie still that and then i
just went bop that's how i got my
username another fun fact about tenza's
name is that he actually changed it from
time to time during his cs go days
occasionally paying homage to legendary
players he looked up to like the
brazilian terminator coldzera but these
days there's no need for him to iterate
on his name because it's pretty clear
his carries enough weight on its own
giving him a moment to strike and the
readjustment he might spot the cross he
decides to pull the trigger for the
adjustment
[Music]
you're an animal
gf buff
okay let's just get this one out of the
way early because we all knew it would
come up if you know even the slightest
bit about tens you will know that he is
in a relationship with hundred thieves
content creator kai day and well they're
cute as it's almost sickening
[Music]
i agree with you obviously having such a
public relationship opens your lives up
to all kinds of attention but it hasn't
stopped the two from growing as content
creators and developing their own
communities together
[Music]
[Applause]
honestly to say that the two have become
one of twitch's biggest power couples
would be an understatement and it's kind
of nice to see these two love struck
zoomers showing the world what a
respectful relationship can look like
eating a cabbage
well
most of the time at least okay i think
that's enough of the surface now let's
get into the things that make tens who
he really is
tens.exe
as you may have noticed the term aimbot
gets thrown around a lot these days in
fact i'm sure we've referred to our fair
share of them over the years
particularly when it comes to cs go and
while tens was certainly known for
hitting his fair share of crispily
suspicious shots in global offensive he
cranked that to 11 when he jumped
to valorente
[Music]
i got him
seriously what is in this dude's water
is he drinking the combined sweat of
xantarus nico and rops whatever his
secret is tens regularly hits shots that
he simply shouldn't be able to
oh my god dude is basically a living
breathing advertisement for aim lab
watching him run his warm-up is enough
to make you go cross-eyed just check it
out for yourself
sheesh
half man half dog in history figures of
importance have often been compared to
animals churchill was the bulldog louis
xi was the spider in a similar fashion
the people closest to tens have started
to equate him with a certain furry
friend that seems like a little like a
little kid dude he's he's like a little
golden retriever you know like a little
puppy
listen uh mike calls him a golden
retriever because uh he's kind of just
like happy to be there and
whatever you say like he'll be like okay
and he's always down having golden
retriever energy is a specific term that
has gained popularity recently and
typically refers to people like tens who
come across as wholesome goofy and
innocent but
i said that's my name
also occasionally a little clueless
how did your cake taste bro what the
that was a while interesting
what
the cake that we made
wait what
not sure how much more this sub can take
but let's take a look at some of tenza's
more personal quirks
who needs color
tens is one of the best valorant players
in the world right now and he's
established himself as that while being
colorblind more specifically he has
protonopia which prevents him from
naturally being able to detect reds
i don't see
anything
i'll say nothing because it is nothing
in our episode of cracked on colorblind
settings in games tens told us about how
he discovered his condition i don't
remember what grade it was it was either
like kindergarten or grade one but it
was like a six
slideshow thing where you have to draw
like a comic strip and it's like a scene
that changes so i drew like i think i
drew like a spider on a spider web like
crawling up a web and then for half of
the
sun i i drew yellow and then for the
other half of the suns i drew green and
then um i think the teacher talked to my
mom and then i went to like the i
uh like doctor and i did like the
numbers test on me i couldn't see
anything
fortunately for tens valorent provides
players with a wide variety of
colorblind mode options to take away
their natural disadvantage
incurable illness
everyone likes to occasionally mess with
their in-game settings whether it's
mouse sensitivity cross hairs or aspect
ratios these seemingly minor details can
help you find your own custom feel for
whatever game it is you're playing and
it's no secret that tens is a bit of a
freak when it comes to adjusting his
in-game settings especially if it means
finding any kind of advantage over his
opposition although not all of his
experiments have worked
fun fact i actually used to play with
left hand in counter-strike but
i switched to right hand just
i don't remember i switched your right
hand near like the end because
i started sucking
listen it's easy to fall down the rabbit
hole and spend way too much time making
micro adjustments to your in-game
settings when you find yourself in a bit
of a rut but tens takes that to the
extreme by doing it mid game
[Music]
now this is the sense
honestly it might be time for tenza's
loved ones to sit him down and have an
honest discussion about this obvious
problem
he knows it's there he just chooses to
do nothing about it
it's kind of like like cigarettes like
every time i switch settings like i get
the nicotine like
like the head rush like
if you or someone you know is suffering
from setting addiction
it's time to get some help
reaching out to tips at the score.com
could be a great first step on your road
to recovery
[Music]
grandma buff
by now most people in the valorette
community understand the term gf buff or
girlfriend buff it chokingly refers to
players in committed relationships who
don't perform well thanks to their own
skill but rather thanks to the
supernatural powers of the gf buff
oh character 14 months is that is that
my girlfriend ogre df tftf jeff gf
yeah
now this is all very cute and wholesome
but what if i told you that there exists
another buff
one far more elusive and one that offers
even more power the grand mop off oh
she's level 900 now um but she has over
10k hours in league
um
number two in n.a for playtime
12th in the world
yes as it turns out tenza's sweet
grandmama absolutely rips a-rams in
league of legends that means tenza's
skill is deeply rooted in his blood i'm
sure there are several of you who are
currently thinking about how to make fun
of league of legends in the comments of
this video but come on it's his grandma
she rips arams that's pretty dope come
on you got to admit it's pretty cool
come on we've made it to the bottom and
wow it's dark
wow did anybody bring an extra
flashlight i haven't got the headlights
replaced yet gaming over
everything
i said we were going to learn some
things today that we didn't expect to so
let me just say it tens only wants one
thing and it's disgusting
ty i want you to sit down and talk with
me
i will in a bit okay i want to play one
more
is league of legends more important to
you than i am it's valor
when it comes to tens it just seems like
gaming comes before everything else in
his life no matter what the conversation
is about video games are always on his
mind i have no idea how many kids i want
i mean if you have three you can make a
rocket league team
because
tens is always thinking about ways he
can get better or more precise and
that's inspired some fairly unusual
practice routines
bpm
i can't do it and here i was just
thinking he played osu because he was a
weeb
[Music]
i'm sorry go for it but i don't give a
i heckin love tens
if you happen to watch valor champions
there's a possibility that you may have
heard this and then someone just types i
hecking love tens bachos yes for many of
the reasons we looked into today fans
and content creators across the world
have decided to let tens know just how
much they love him
how much you ask um i just wanted to ask
shazam i have two questions for you my
first question is uh who are your
favorites for the event and my second
question is do you heck and love tens
that chest
favorites i'd say us game bits are given
um nv2 they're the guys that beat us
last time and that just i couldn't love
10. i always have to say i hecking like
tens i can't love pen
what a song
good morning so exciting
baby
but i can't help but feel that many
people are unaware of the origins of the
ihekan lovetens meme and the bat chest
emote that often accompanies it so i'll
try and explain it as quickly as
possible
that's right we're doing meme content
bat chest this man with the light up
goggles was popularized by forsen's
community it's typically spammed when
something unexpected happens or to mock
someone for getting overly excited and
in typical fashion forsen's community
took the popular chat emote and turned
it into a text-to-speech song
that's hacking epic wow
that's hacking cool too oh
so how did this meme become attached to
tens well our theory is that it's
because it's intended to be used to poke
fun at those who are a little too
enthusiastic it perfectly pokes fun at
the borderline obsession valorent fans
have with sentinel's star do list
look there's no denying that tenza is a
great gamer and a pretty cool dude but
at the same time he's still a young man
and maybe everyone's getting a little
carried away at least just a little bit
while we did it we managed to explore
the entire tens iceberg
isn't it glorious
you know what
i feel like i learned something maybe we
could all be a little bit more like tens
at times enjoy the simple things in life
be eager and helpful and most
importantly
be yourself
so we need to cook food
oh my god sorry
that that scared the out of me
if i had a bag full of other people's
teeth
that would be super weird and i don't
just to clarify i don't have a bag of
other people's teeth and i
i i i'm not i i don't i don't want other
people's teeth i listen bro i i barely
want my own teeth like i need them but
but like i'm not super interested in
them so you know it's fine